[Music]
and that's my life news submitted by
Chuck Taylors hey my favorites
a woman plans to sue Jennifer Lopez
claiming she stole her life story for a
new movie she's Jenny from the block -
what's going on with [ __ ] JLo one man
cheated on her supposedly hey rod ed
laughs oh and then now this who's life
this she's still because I want to steal
Jennifer Lopez's life I want that
woman's life whoever she is also
Jennifer Lopez's body
I want her skin oh yeah she's dwell this
[ __ ] is 60 or something do you hurt me
yeah I've never heard that once in my
life no right now with your short hair
remember what she had short hair and
then she had glasses
I forgot what movie that was maybe you
guys know any skin looks so pretty right
now thank you thank you
you only had to say three [ __ ] times
that Bush doesn't get compliments cuz
you never receives them verbally humped
her leg oh you like [ __ ] says it at
the weirdest time I'm all crying you're
so beautiful my insult you so bad I seen
it again once I would get like horny
whenever I loved it when girls cry I
think it's hot as [ __ ] I when Nicki
cries I get a little bit literally
turned off I know this is really like I
cried and then like I reached over him
and I felt his dick I was like why are
you hard right now he goes I don't know
how to tell you this but why would you
feel his dick no cuz I reached oh yeah
why would you feel as like you were
crying like I was like why are you
alright he goes I don't know what it is
but I get really turned on when you
crying oh my god
Filipino boys man their [ __ ] you're
like and we had the craziest [ __ ] man
except for z/os you got cry sex no
that's a deal-breaker turned on when
Nikki cries I have a thing for watching
her cry for some reason I love taking
her to weddings ah no it's almost like
um that I could that my dick is so big
that it could hurt her and
really the [ __ ] case no I know but
that's part of why I enjoy it so when
she comes home every time she comes home
she sees that you put in like a walk
through memory she's like [ __ ] oh yeah
I'm like let's watch sin was last night
and she's like yeah I'm like no it's
just or chalices her face from across
the room had figured out my ring
password all right so this woman here
that is planning to sue JLo because you
stole her life that's funny she knows
that JLo had nothing to do with any
movies or anything right well her name
is Samantha barbash so she used to prey
on the wolf of Wall Street she would
drug these rich men usually they were
married damn cardi B I know right and
it's funny you mentioned her because
she's also in this movie oh I'll say
it's funny you mentioned that at all cuz
I think that's just funny so this movie
is called hustlers and the Hollywood
version of this is like for strippers
who hustle our way to get money out of
the men who take advantage of them and
cardi B using this Marty reason that's
so funny really funny the true life
story it also takes place in the Bronx
but the difference here is that Samantha
and her friends that were doing this
they weren't strippers they would just
hustle these dudes think they would go
out with them in clubs or whatever and
then they would drug them they would put
like ketamine and then they would end up
charging up their credit cards like
crazy at these certain clubs then they
would get a cut from the waitresses
because they would leave fat ass tips
and that's all these girls would get
cuts from that they purposely would try
to get these guys that were married or
they had something to lose not until one
of the guys that they hustle they could
no I don't give a [ __ ] so he went to the
cops and then unraveled the fact that
they had this whole scheme well he said
like [ __ ] my marriage mmm pretty much
he's like this is my way out this is
actually pretty common my stripper
friends are like dude like like dudes
are coked out and drunk spend more money
it's not it's not something it's not a
secret
yeah but how dare you because your
acquaintance mr. Bill Cosby booth you
know you know how everyone say that
right now oh yeah because Bill Cosby did
this [ __ ] it's not okay the cardi B did
the [ __ ] and I'm like wait a minute
cardi B was supposed to [ __ ] these guys
she
drugs them so she doesn't have to [ __ ]
up and then just takes the money they
were gonna pay her there's a difference
between robbery and rape you [ __ ]
white a lot of people out there they're
[ __ ] stood I'm not thinking it
through you don't they just hear key
words and they're like I'm gonna make my
assumption because I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're calling car DB Cosby they have a
shame they're saying it's the same [ __ ]
wow that's crazy
like what this is completely [ __ ]
different it's crazy
so cardi B she was she just she was
drugging them and then robbing them
right yeah she would get them from the
strip club take him to a hotel room
which they were gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] he
legally uh and then yeah the money that
they were gonna pay her like you said
she would just shock him
so I will say that that is a you know
she broke her promise yeah probably a
pinky promise too and that is bad if you
said you're gonna [ __ ] a guy for money
and you don't do it you should do it at
least [ __ ] and I think that that's the
part that I have a problem but the then
she she didn't do that and so then she
just took the money from their wallet I
don't know why I feel this way whatever
happens on it an illegal transaction is
already illegal this is black market but
you know what's crazy I'm getting so
much heat right now because I'd that
people took these Wilson cuz you're a
[ __ ] mother okay she's a mom you
monsters you let us do the talking right
I'll take all the heat give a seven to
me Stevie called me on Instagram good
podcast sooo fall upon cast even icky
there you go should they don't tell you
pop they don't tell you these poor men
using prostitutes robbing these poor men
who are cheating on their wives and
doing illegal dick sucking on the side
like whatever happens in those black
market type of [ __ ] it's your risk that
you take these are the same guys who
they'd watch the Chris Hansen okay to
catch a predator thing and they this
[ __ ] this is a traveler yeah
absolutely oh man guys the same does
that buy a stolen car and their
complaint that a/c doesn't work yeah
what the [ __ ] do you want help the AC
it's a stolen car take it back and leave
a note it says if you should fix your
a/c I love it oh she seems like a hairy
person I bet you J Lo's older than this
[ __ ] and she still looks better [ __ ]
crazy kills hot tell me that drinking
baby blood or whatever they do
transfusing your body would be but that
what she does I guarantee your skin's
crazy
JLo and what's her name do we need to
spend that much money on your skin care
of course you know dude even J Lo's
fingers look harder than this vision
that can afford more than JLo that don't
even come close to her what is she doing
it's the Latina blood yeah and then here
is JLo and character again God yeah or
the movie hustlers crazy then she's like
70 she has AB still that's great why'd
she get all right older dude what the
[ __ ] is going on that's still pretty old
51 or 48 or some [ __ ] like that's oh she
go to the surface and the Sun what
happened to her old lady from Futurama
she [ __ ] vacation and a [ __ ]
volcano and [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ] but why
should JLo you [ __ ] money-hungry
[ __ ] because she's saying like well she
never came to me to find out the real
story I like to portray but why does
this [ __ ] think that JLo wrote it yes
that's not J Lo's like a job though it's
very stupid oh hang on a second let's
have let's think about this for a second
cuz if you're an actor you're supposed
to meet the person you're playing are
you supposed to be happy if you want to
get annoyed season you're supposed to
for summary we did that Daniel day-lewis
didn't meet Abraham Lincoln just know I
lived out a quarter or Jenna to beat him
for like three months in West Virginia
or some Shady's walking around
Confederate money paying for shoes
about her JLo is a producer on the film
no but that doesn't mean she wrote sure
I know ya guys amazing dude he's like
[ __ ] shooting rabbits with a pellet
gun it was like what are you doing
Daniel then he's like Oh mr. Lincoln to
you sir yeah how many shades for that
mother yeah whoa I already said in a
lovely reinhardt Julia Stiles keke
palmer Mercedes Ruehl who's first ad I
want to know who's deep here well
Farrell and Ann McKay is also producers
oh cool so she thinks that this is a
story about her as if she's the only ho
in Wall Street that's like [ __ ]
around dudes for money and drugging them
up like really I think it is literally
her story though it sounds like they
kind of took her story but they're kind
of like twisting a little bit and
especially the fact that they in the
movie they're strippers was the method
like this is defamation you are not we
were [ __ ] like it's it's very common
in that world yeah that you drug men to
take money from that's true though right
yeah it's a lot of people do this you're
special [ __ ] out like why is she she
said that she's planning on writing a
book well too [ __ ] late she said it
came out with a long time ago cuz like
what is she suing on like you copied my
story that's not really I don't have an
answer
yeah but Bart she's been meaning to get
around to it okay she's a top dollar
[ __ ] yeah yeah
well no cuz strippers don't make as much
money as those top dollar [ __ ] so I
bet you she feels like it's defamation
because people think she made less money
can use baby that's right she's like
yeah the clubs that we were in had no
poles anyway then oh my god this lady is
[ __ ] bonkers she's trying she's just
like debunking her whole thing nice she
goes actually none of the stories like
mine at all dump it doing we don't use
ketamine we use blue blow darts so
nothing's are like
exactly they got it all wrong she's I
said they're like
[Laughter]
she should say everything's exactly the
same yeah [ __ ] yeah
[Music]